100 man
um now you've had a crazy year in the
sense that uh first of all
you and ruby rose had a pretty wild
public relationship
yeah you know i'm assuming that's over
that's over with yeah how how uh you
know how was it
being in a public relationship like that
where
you know whenever it just seemed like
things you know sometimes got a little
sloppy on the internet and then you know
people coming up with assumptions about
your life and
yeah how was that i mean it's just it's
annoying
to be honest public relationships are
very hard
it's not as easy as people think for
everybody to have opinions on it
so it's like you know it's stressful you
got millions of people in your business
facts i mean it's like you can't do you
can't have a private
relationship you know well especially
both of you guys are
public figures that's what i'm saying so
it's like you know we make money off the
internet
what do you think went wrong uh with
your with with you guys in particular
what you tried to get what type of title
are you trying to get in this video i
don't know man
you're the youtube guy
i don't know you know was it just like
you think it was like some of the public
pressure or just you know
yeah no we still cool though you guys
are still cool yeah
it's just you know stuff happens you
know relationships
go on and off you know you get into
arguments and you push
did she start her only fans while she
was with you
yeah i haven't subscribed so i don't
know what kind of content's on it right
and i know you were one of the first
celebrities i remember seeing startup
only fans where you were like yo if you
want some game
subscribe to my only fans because i got
some game for you yeah about you know
which i thought was dope
yeah i want to get into some of that
game but but like
is that uh you know being
in a relationship and then the girl gets
to olding fans is that you know is that
a
weird conversation or no i think every
girl in the world
should have only fans every girl in the
world should have only fans it's the
easiest money in the world
i don't know why i'm just i'm just
saying that's just how i feel though you
know what i mean i don't it doesn't
bother me at all i'm like [ __ ] get your
money you know
and um saying every girl in the world
should have a holding fans doesn't mean
every girl in the world should
you know all right yeah you ain't got it
you ain't got to be doing that you're
crazy
some of these girls are finessing their
their ways
it's the [ __ ] you can see on instagram
there's some girls on only fans that's
really getting
hit oh for sure they on there doing some
crazy [ __ ] but like
you could just go on there and just be
you yeah i went on there and i was a
teacher
i'm damn near a professional on my [ __ ]
you know what i mean so it's like
you went the opposite route of tiger
yeah i went to opposite route but
i was finished transition you were gonna
you were gonna throw the johnson up on
there
no no no no no no because they yo tiger
was trending on twitter
i was like i wanna off
god damn tiger i can't do that [ __ ] come
on yeah
like what are we doing we rapping we're
doing porn we're doing
maybe i don't see what the point of that
is
but i guess there's some publicity [ __ ]
i might it's a money play
it's money play i might [ __ ] around i
feel like tiger's low-key you know
if there's a such thing as only fans
pimping he started his little two-raw
agency
that's what nick that's what [ __ ] do
though like he's not the first to do
that [ __ ] do that bro like
only fantastic it's real like so what
goes behind that if you got friends who
do it like is it
i mean [ __ ] might just they might just
find a few girls
you know they look good a lot
film video you know like look i can help
get your only fans popping but you gotta
give me a yeah you
shout out to 8 ball and mjg that's crazy
he's illegal
that [ __ ] is crazy yeah